[Rock music exhilarating]
Douglas: My name is Anthony Douglas, Founder and CEO of Hole19.
Seeking Hole19 to design
The largest network of golfers gather and interact with them.
We aim to provide a link between golfers around the world.
We try to participate in the golfers' trip
Before, during and after the game.
[Rock music exhilarating]
Golf has always been a source of passion for me.
I started the idea in 2007 when I was working with a golf instructor.
I took advantage of them to follow up on me statistics and communicate with the coach
To help me improve my skills.
I decided to create a new company in this field.
It was a great way to combine my passion and my work.
[Rock music exhilarating]
We designed the product in Portugal.
In Lisbon specifically.
KUNA team of designers to help us design.
Four and a half to five years later, the number of users was approximately 1 million.
The moment we discovered Android Wear, we realized that it was our only tool
To achieve what we aspire to.
Not much like golfers
Consider the phone a lot,
That's what made us think about using smart clock.
Given the hardware and software components, we realized that Android Wear was the perfect solution
For us.
Carpalho: Since the launch of Wear, we have noticed a great welcome from users
And positive comments, this helped us
In access to a broader base of users exceed twice the users six months ago.
We noticed that the monthly activity rate
Android Wear users reached 40%.
Android Wear provides us with a more interactive forum.
In fact, some users only benefit from Hole19
On Android Wear.
We believe that this is the result of the great efforts we have made
In development.
As a developer I was switching to Android Wear
It is fairly easy, given the quality of wearable devices.
One of the most important experiences in the golf course is the possibility
Know the distance and wind speed.
It's a feature that makes switching from phone to clock
Is very useful.
There is an important thing to consider when developing applications
For use in Wear, a connection must always be available
Between phone and application.
Therefore, we used the Data Layer API
Which provided us with the ease of doing so,
This is due to the dependence on
Exchange simple and appropriate data.
After launching the new Android Wear 2.0 release,
We have access to a wide range of features
Which can give a better user experience.
We use API Complications,
Since we want the user to feel in constant contact with Hole19.
We want him to know just by looking at the background of the hour's quick information
Such as information on disability rate, average outcome,
The number of days passed on
Another golf match.
- The moment of founding of the company was a wonderful moment,
When I spent six hours
In the planning of golf courses.
My information was limited, but after a few years,
1 million users.
I did not expect such success,
I did not expect to join
30 people to our company.
Our efforts have been very successful.